Salut. Aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé personne à mentaliser
donc je vais vous mentaliser, vous !
On va faire une expérience interactive, un petit bluff comme ça entre nous.
Mais pour ça, il faut que vous soyez concentrés absolument sur la vidéo.
Cette expérience va être basée sur quelque chose que vous connaissez bien sur Youtube
Il s'agit des pouces en l'air et des pouces en bas.
Les fameux pouces en bas
J'ai une anecdote par rapport aux pouces en bas.
Depuis le début que je fais des vidéos, donc depuis mi-janvier à peu près
tous les jours, au moment où je mets la vidéo, moins d'une minute après
j'ai deux pouces en bas.
Ce sont les mêmes personnes qui se précipitent pour mettre un pouce en bas.
C'est devenu une mission pour eux
Le plus drôle, c'est que, quand même, je connais l'un des deux personnellement
Et bien je te remercie parce que tu m'as donné l'idée de faire cette vidéo.
Vous voyez donc maintenant apparaître un pouce en l'air et un pouce en bas
Mettez votre doigt sur un des deux pouces, celui qui est en l'air ou celui qui est en bas, c'est vous qui choisissez
Vous mettez votre doigt sur l'un des deux pouces
Vous allez maintenant épeler votre prénom
Et à chaque lettre que vous allez épeler, vous allez bouger votre doigt d'une seule case.
J'explique histoire que ce soit bien clair.
Si j'ai décidé de mettre mon doigt sur le pouce en bas pour commencer
et que j'épele mon prénom, donc Fabien
Je vais bouger en faisant :
Donc vous avez votre doigt sur un des deux pouces, celui que vous avez choisi au départ
Maintenant allez-y, épelez votre prénom
Et à chaque lettre que vous épelez, vous changez votre doigt de pouce
Je crois que c'est pas exactement ça qu'il fallait faire
Vous avez maintenant terminé, votre doigt est sur l'un des deux pouces
Si votre doigt est sur le pouce vert, vous allez maintenant épeler le mot "VERT" : V-E-R-T
en changeant votre doigt de place à chaque fois que vous épelez une lettre
et si votre doigt est sur le pouce rouge
vous faites la même chose mais en épelant le mot "ROUGE"
Si moi par exemple j'étais sur le rouge, je ferai
R
O
U
etc. etc.
Si vous êtes sur le vert, vous épelez le mot "VERT", si vous êtes sur le rouge, vous épelez le mot "ROUGE"
C'est parti
Et ce coup-ci c'est bon
Vous êtes arrivé sur un pouce, sur un pouce et un seul pouce
Et c'est sur ce pouce-là que vous cliquerez à la fin de la vidéo
POUCE EN L'AIR
C'était une petite vidéo du mardi, un peu différente, voilà
on a fait un jeu entre nous
Espérons que ce jeu-là vous ait plu
Demain, c'est le jour des astuces
Je vais vous donner des astuces sur les techniques des manipulateurs
Demain également, donc mercredi soir à 20h50
Sur la chaîne numéro 23, donc en prime-time
Y a une émission qui s'appelle "Dossiers surnaturels"
sur les mentalistes, les hypnotiseurs, etc.
Et j'y serai en tant que mentaliste
Si jamais vous regardez, faites-le moi savoir sur Twitter en mettant notre Hashtag à nous
C'est le Hashtag qu'on a déterminé l'autre jour
lors du live sur Periscope, c'était samedi
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à ma chaîne et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog. Ciao !